vous étiez avec les parents euh de
Vanessa ce soir qu'est-ce qui vous ont
dit les parents
avec le problème récupéré le corps de
Vanessa ils veulent le transporter le
remède
en Espagne c'est plein de questions mais
en même temps il se posent la question
qui d'où il est est-ce qu'il est marrant
est-ce qu'il est de Tonneins maintenant
ils savent qu'est-ce qui va se passer ce
qui va être condamné c'est toutes ces
questions que se posent les parents mais
avant tout c'est la tristesse c'est la
tristesse c'est Vanessa qui n'est plus
là et Vanessa vous ne connaissez qu'un
prénom et Vanessa c'était une
adolescente de 14 ans qui aimait la
musique qui jouait du violon qui avait
des camarades qui qui s'étaient la joie
de vivre et Vanessa n'est plus là et
Cyril Hanouna si vous le permettez notre
département porte là encore une tâche
individuelle on a eu Magali on a eu
Marion et encore maintenant Vanessa
nous sommes très inquiets nous sommes
tristes et aussi en colère et les
parents bien évidemment c'est leur
sentiment que je vaux que je vous
retransmet c'est ce qu'ils vivent et
c'est ce qu'on vit avec
on comprend tout à fait votre colère ici
vraiment vraiment
comme on dit voilà on n'en peut plus
d'apprendre des drames toutes les
semaines tous les deux jours
Annie vous avez parlé de la
tristesse des parents est-ce que c'est
mêlés à de la colère ou et pour
l'instant il se posent juste des
questions
c'est beaucoup de tristesse beaucoup de
tristesse et il se posent les questions
vous savez ce sont des gens qui sont en
France depuis à peine un an et quelques
mois il possède pas notre langue c'est
difficile pour eux aussi d'exprimer de
colère mais on sent très bien chez le
papa que la colère commence à brander
quand il a pris par exemple je suis
triste individu était récidiviste et
c'est vrai que nous pour le moment il
faut qu'ils sont encore j'allais presque
dire dans une phase de sidération encore
et je suppose des questions mais c'est
pas possible comment ça s'est passé
comment comment est-elle monter dans
cette voiture c'est toute cette question
qui reviennent et c'est cette tristesse
qui a dans la maison
on va revenir bien sûr sur ce qui s'est
passé dans un instant que Michel Marie
merci Annie d'avoir été avec nous merci
beaucoup Annie merci merci beaucoup
Annie président de l'association l'amour
était merci Annie merci Michel Marie
c'est donc vendredi à la sortie du
collège que l'adolescente va être
kidnappée elle rentrait chez elle pour
déjeuner il est 13h Cyril elle quitte
son cours de sport et elle a environ un
kilomètre 300 à parcours et à pied pour
aller déjeuner elle reprend un cours de
mathématiques cette fois à 14 heures
donc timing serré elle quitte l'école
elle elle marche elle a fait environ 800
mètres elle arrive dans une rue qui est
la rue de la maison et à partir de là
elle se volatilise
il y a un gros retard pour ce qui est de
l'alerte mais combien de temps pour
rentrer chez elle normalement 20 minutes
d'accord 20 minutes un quart d'heure 20
minutes en gros d'accord ce sont des
rues qui sont fréquentées ou pas trop
alors c'est une petite ville de 9000
habitants
elle disparaît à côté de la gendarmerie
nationale
[Musique]
j'ai envie de vous dire que c'est c'est
vraiment pas de chance parce que à midi
on peut avoir des gendarmes qui rentrent
à la caserne pour déjeuner des gens qui
en sortent
elle a été enlevée en quelques secondes
il n'y avait a priori aucun témoin à
part heureusement les caméras elle va
être suivie par une voiture c'est ça
alors
les gendarmes sont saisis tardivement je
dis 18h45 je crois l'alerte est donnée à
18h45 les gens là vont faire un travail
absolument remarquable en deux heures
ils vont éplucher toute la vidéo il y a
28 caméras dans ce dans ce village enfin
dans cette ville ils vont éplucher
toutes les caméras toutes les images
donc dans la fourchette de temps qu'ils
intéresse et faut savoir que les caméras
ça marche on vous avait pas un flux
continu donc on repère Vanessa à un
endroit de la rue et à la caméra
suivante on la voit plus
et à ce moment là on s'intéresse aux
voitures qui sont passés à peu près au
même moment et là il y a une Volkswagen
Passat grise vieux modèle qui intéresse
les gendarmes la plaque
d'immatriculation et lisible et à partir
de là ils vont identifier ce le
propriétaire du véhicule ils vont tomber
sur un garçon qui s'appelle romain qui a
31 ans et qui habite dans un petit
village
un peu plus loin et ils vont
Marmande il habite à Marmande et un
23h45 qui vont procéder à son
interpellation alors normalement c'est
6h du matin mais là on peut imaginer que
Vanessa est toujours vivante et qu'elle
est retenue vivante à l'intérieur donc
sur ordre du parquet ils ont ils ont
rentrés ils ont interpellé
alors quelle est la réaction du suspect
quand les gendarmes viennent interpeller
directement et il a dit au gendarme je
sais pourquoi vous êtes vous êtes là et
en gros il a vu immédiatement avant même
d'être placé en garde à vue il reconnaît
les faits c'est
très curieux comme c'est rare et c'est
curieux se laisse appréhender tout de
suite il dit voilà il fait aucune
difficulté quand il voit les uniformes
de la gendarmerie nationale il dit je
sais pourquoi vous êtes là et il se
laisse il se laisse emmener et j'en veux
pour preuve que moins de deux heures
plus tard il a donné l'endroit où il
avait abandonné le corps de cette
malheureuse Vanessa et les gendarmes
étaient sur place et découvraient et
découvrez le corps donc comme vous dites
vous a passé très rapidement aux aveux
il va même pas
c'est un délinquant très particulier
c'est une criminalité très particulière
et tuer la jeune fille enlèvement
séquestration viol et meurtre
et là pour ça il encourt la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
ce qui interroge évidemment c'est le
profil du suspect c'est voilà je vois
tous les gens qui restent là dessus il
est 21h04 on est en direct et il était
déjà connu des services de police oui
alors oui il était connu des services de
police il était mineur il avait 15 ans
il a été poursuit pour une agression
sexuelle donc c'est pas un viol c'est
agression sexuelle c'est un cran en
dessous et par sa qualité de mineur il a
été condamné à une peine de 15 jours de
prison avec sursis et évidemment il a
pas été incarcéré il a
il a cette il est connu il est il est
connu des antécédents judits des
antécédents judiciaires le l'autre
difficulté c'est qu'il était pas inscrit
au figeste qui est le fichier des
délinquants sexuels des auteurs de
crimes sexuels et là encore parce qu'il
était mineur on a considéré que c'était
peut-être pas utile de le
suivi psychologique après il est parti
dans la nature
moi c'est ce qui me choque quand même
c'est que 15 jours avec sursis deux ans
de mise à l'épreuve et comme c'est du
sursis pas de suivi c'est à dire que cet
homme au profil quand même dont on voit
qu'il est extrêmement préoccupant à
partir de 2006 puisque il avait 15 ans
en 2006 certes plus rien on verra
l'enquête vérifiera exactement 2011
exactement ce qui s'est passé après mais
moi ce qui me choque c'est que quand
même avec cette agression sexuelle
commise à 15 ans il n'y a pas eu de
suivi Cyril ça c'est quand même très
étonnant c'est un profil on le voit là
qui aurait mérité d'être suivi c'est
impossible de laisser des gens comme ça
sans les contrôler là franchement moi je
suis extrêmement choqué je peux me
permettre il a 15 ans c'est pas
forcément c'est bien évidemment pas une
excuse je ne connais pas la nature des
faits qu'il a qu'il a commis
si ça se trouve c'est peut-être pas
grand chose je dis si ça se trouve je
n'en sais rien
[Musique]
parce que de toute façon c'est vrai que
la sanction de 15 jours de prison est un
petit peu semble un peu désuète donc
voilà mais je sais pas quels sont les
faits il était pas fiché comme
délinquant sexuel il n'était pas aux
figeas d'accord comment il est décrit
par son entourage alors c'est quelqu'un
qui est natif de Seine-Maritime il a
vécu toute son enfance en Seine-Maritime
il a 31 ans aujourd'hui
il s'est installé il a quitté la
Seine-Maritime pour s'installer du côté
de Bordeaux à Bègles très exactement il
avait trouvé un petit boulot
tout allait à peu près bien mais il
faisait quand même il était limite
limite clochard
il avait jamais un sous-vêtement il
était intérimaire dans le dans le jardin
là dans les entretien des espaces verts
d'accord et bon il avait une il avait
une compagne il avait un enfant une
fille je crois
aujourd'hui ça c'est
pardon il y a également un bébé de d'un
mois mais c'est bien évidemment avant
donc il avait un enfant de qui a 5 ans
aujourd'hui il se sépare avec cette
femme il ne voit plus sa fille il se met
à la picole il se met également à fumer
du shit et
idira idéal jusqu'au jour où il
rencontre une femme c'est en septembre
2021 donc c'est assez récent une femme
avec laquelle
va flasher c'est à l'occasion d'un
barbecue
il tombe amoureux de cette femme elle
s'appelle Samira et elle habite par
Mende et donc il va la suivre il va
planter beige il va planter son boulot
il va tout planter et il s'installe à
Marmande
il vit avec cette cette femme Samira
avec qui il était au moment de son
arrestation et effectivement il a eu
avec cette femme un enfant qui est né il
y a trois semaines un mois voilà en gros
le profil
pardon alors il travaille où il a trouvé
un boulot d'intérimaire dans les dans
les eaux et forêts mais dans le
l'entretien des jardins des voilà alors
c'est collègues ont été interrogés ils
disaient que tu le trouvais un petit peu
bizarre
oui c'est Julie c'est limite limite de
la cloche
le jour des faits quelques jours avant
on l'a vu en train de de vider des
bières à l'intérieur de son véhicule le
matin des faits avant qu'il passe à
l'action à l'acte pardon il fumait des
joints dans cette même voiture il était
en limite de clochardisation il était
retenu à mon avis par un fil par cette
femme
et voilà en gros le le le profil de ce
alors Michel Marie qu'est-ce qu'il a dit
lorsqu'il a été appelé il s'est passé
quoi ce qu'il avait repéré
Vanessa cette adolescente de 14 ans ou
est-ce que c'était le fruit du hasard
c'est d'après ce qu'il raconte le fait
du hasard il est dans sa voiture il est
il est devant cette école
il fume pétard sur pétard et arrive 13h
il repère cette cette gamine cette
petite fille 14 ans
il la suit je veux dire sur 800 mètres
approximativement et au moment où il y a
personne dans cette rue il
l'appréhende il la rentre de force dans
son dans son véhicule la personne n'a
rien vu il y a personne apparemment
personne n'a rien vu c'est
comme ça il rentre de force dans son
véhicule il rentre de force dans son
véhicule
il sort de la ville
il trouve un endroit tranquille pour
faire malheureusement ce qui l'avait ce
qu'il avait envie de faire
et puis l'étrangle de peur d'être
reconnu et donc d'être d'être oui
reconnu et arrêté et ensuite il a il va
se débarrasser du corps dans une vieille
maison abandonnée
qui est à une quinzaine de kilomètres de
là c'est une maison qui est en bord de
route
dans laquelle personne ne rentre jamais
et
elle a un propriétaire mais je crois que
ça fait 42 ans d'après le journaliste de
chez moi qui a fait l'enquête sur le
terrain
ça fait 42 ans elle appartient à
l'agriculteur et temps en temps il
apprenne pour des concerts ou pour des
mecs qui veulent faire le bœuf et il a
abandonné le corps dans cette dans cette
maison
un peu désaffectée et il est rentré chez
lui et
la gendarmerie est venue et la
gendarmerie
des regrets si vous savez
évoqué le terme de pulsion voilà selon
les premiers éléments une position voilà
une fin regret absolument pas une
pulsion c'est quelqu'un qui est décrit
aussi comme colérique impulsif avec une
double personnalité mais c'est vrai que
le terme de de pulsion là également me
choque parce que pulsion on a
l'impression que déjà il prépare une
pulsion avec voyez ce que je veux dire
d'altération
est-ce que vous allez dire euh Géraldine
et Gilles parce qu'après on va dire que
on veut une justice expéditive
c'est comme sur voilà
donc c'est incroyable la faire Lola on
sait même plus où ça en est où c'est que
la meurtrière de certainement nous
regarder à la télévision tranquillement
pendant que les parents de Lola ont
perdu leur fille et tout va bien voilà
donc on a pas le droit de le dire ça
donc il faut pas le dire
en revanche il faut savoir le parcours
de ce type là pour savoir s'il y a pas
de justement
dire parce qu'il a évoqué une pulsion et
je voudrais pas que ça serve plus tard
parce que j'ai déjà entendu l'avocat
aussi qui prépare ça et ça ça le même
cas que jubilar
mettez juste la page de du nouveau
détective remettez la une la une à les
glaçantes alors on va pas faire la
justice nous regardez juste la Une de ça
regardez juste la Une de ça qui sont ces
gens moi il y a une phrase que je
voudrais enlever à vie j'ai enterré mon
enfant il y a pas plus terrible comme
phrase dans la vie que j'ai enterré mon
enfant on peut pas comprendre ce que
c'est cette phrase là on peut pas
comprendre comprendre ça et il y a des
mecs comme ça qui ont 30 ans qui se
baladent avec des voitures qui repèrent
des jeunes filles parce que c'est
celle-là mais ça se trouve il y en a
d'autres il est repère il est maître
dans les voitures il est viole il les
étrangle et après j'ai une pulsion et
moi je vous le dis et je vous je vous le
redis encore ici c'est ce mec-là moi ce
mec-là pour moi n'a rien à faire dans
notre société pulsion ou pas pulsion je
me répète à chaque fois c'est comme
Mathieu qui dit c'est des faits divers à
chaque fois il a raison Mathieu c'est
des faits divers regardez c'est une il
se prend pour qui lui pour enlever la
vie d'une jeune fille il se prend pour
qui il a 30 ans il a une pulsion il
enlève la vie de quelqu'un de 14 ans
voilà bah je suis désolé je suis désolé
continue comme ça je veux pas qu'on a
juste ici justement est-ce que ça aurait
pu être évité est-ce que il y a des gens
qui disent avec et comme il avait des
antécédents mais ça aurait pas pu être
invité c'est difficile c'est c'est une
criminalité qu'on ne contrôle pas qu'on
ne maîtrise pas on peut pas mettre déjà
quand de toute façon lui était pas fiché
comme ça le problème est réglé on donc
lui on avait aucune chance de le repérer
mais combien de gens peuvent avoir ce
profil des milliers j'imagine c'est pour
ça que c'est difficilement traçable
Michel là vous me surprenez parce qu'il
était pas fiché mais il était pas suivi
il était pas suivi mais c'est incroyable
pas Michel il a rien à voir là
[Musique]
certainement aussi des milliers comment
peut-on suivre
des dizaines de milliers ma question
c'est pourquoi il sort quand il a 50 ans
c'est ça ma question parce que les Lola
toutes ces jeunes filles il a 14 ans qui
sont violées agressés comme si c'était
on sent si on jouait les mecs qui
sortent à 50 piges là là je dis
peut-être des bêtises mais on dit
perpétuité la perpétuité ça n'existe pas
on est bien d'accord
ils font
il peut pas faire une demande pour
sortir
elle va être refusée
moi ça déjà pourquoi il demande alors
donc c'est quoi c'était on pouvait pas
on pouvait pas éviter d'arbre alors ce
que je disais c'est que il y a des
services très spécialisés pour le
terrorisme par exemple on repère un
individu qui seradicalise qui fréquente
une mosquée etc bref les services de
renseignement travaillent sur lui le
mettre sur écoute le suivre etc là c'est
pas possible là c'est pas possible parce
que ce type avant de de commettre ce
alors je sais que vous allez me
reprendre là dessus mais avant qu'il
commette son ce crime il vit avec une
femme il avait un bébé il donnait
l'apparence d'un d'un type peut-être un
peu borderline mais certainement pas à
l'image de ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il a
fait donc ils sont repérable on est
quand même très très en retard sur dans
tout ce qui est psychologique
merci en tout cas d'être venu nous voir
encore sur cette affaire qui va nous
rendre fou une fois de plus voilà vous
voyez à ce plateau voilà on a la mare
d'entendre des affaires comme ça merci
en tout cas merci une chose rendre un
petit hommage à mon confrère Vincent
Senecal du nouveau détective qui a fait
une remarquable enquête et qui est donc
dans le journal qui